I'm not going to show up from Ichi can
yeah listen
how are you doing how are you handling
all this self isolation it's like day by
day some days I'm like I'm great
I'm loving this I'm so relaxed and
rejuvenated and then other days I'm like
is the world ending is everybody okay
like what's happening it's really day by
day I struggle openly with anxiety and
this is like a different kind of anxiety
like this this is like I constantly I'm
questioning if I have the virus because
my chest is constantly tight and then
I'm like in my head about it where I'm
like do I have it because I'm short of
breath and then I realize it's just
anxiety to cope with that anxiety
Caitlyn has been keeping busy with your
podcast multiple businesses and of
course
tik-tok yes like I was judging it before
I even got on it so I was like you know
my niece and nephew are on it I was like
I think it's for young young like young
kids and then I started getting into it
I'm like oh no this is this is like my
jam this is where I'm supposed to be
like you also having some pretty epic
dog parties tell us a little bit about
the Isle of hosting I love throwing
parties and this is like a nightmare to
me that I can't just have my girlfriends
over or host any parties and so we
decided to throw a party for the dogs
they didn't really appreciate it as much
as we thought they would they were tired
from playing all days so it turned into
a party for just Jason and myself I
don't know what I would do without him
and the dogs here during this time now
movin nineteen the filming of players
season obviously has hit the skids yeah
how do you think she'll be as a
Bachelorette I would never want my
children having a father like you
it just thinks she's in a place in her
life where I would believe a love story
and I believe she's there to find it and
knows what she wants so I was really
excited for that season everything
happens for a reason I think they had
needed to recast to the guys I think
they're too young I think they're gonna
be able to do that but when it all comes
like I think she's gonna have the
opportunity and I think it's gonna be a
really really great season